hi I'm Erik Bosse and hereditary is
really one of the most frightening films
I've ever seen specifically for the way
the mystery in the horror imagery come
together in a final sequence that it's
just truly what the just God
everything's wrong I need to go to
church and if you're we actually look
something like that I'm betting you also
had some questions about what exactly
you just saw so here I'm gonna break
down hereditary Zenden tie in what
seemed like loose ends and explain the
deeper meaning of all of this cool
that's boiler warning if you haven't
seen hereditary all right now turn on
all the lights in the room grab a Bible
and let's get started first and foremost
what the hell just happened
to be specific what happened in the
attic and in the ceremony in the
treehouse
hereditary ends by revealing that the
hauntings experienced by Annie Toni
Collette and her son Peter Alex Wolff
are not hallucinations brought on by the
family's tragedies most recently the
shocking death of the daughter Charlie
they're actually all part of a
conspiracy by a demonic cult led by
Annie's mother Ellen to provide a male
human host to be possessed by a demon
named Peyman the creepy random naked
people at their house are all members of
this cult and Annie's possessed body
suffers its own head in preparation for
the final ceremony to match the
decapitation of her mother and her
daughter after Peter jumps out the
window we see a ghostly light flash over
his body now we had seen this same
mirrored light throughout the film it
was used to indicate the demons presence
was near now the light settles on Peter
telling us that Peyman has taken control
of him that's why when he rises he
clicks just like his sister used to the
demon once inhabited her now he resides
in Peter Peter climbs into the treehouse
for the coronation ceremony the director
loaded the scene with sacrilegious
imagery describing it as Christ's manger
but the king arriving here is an evil
one the statue is a mannequin not a
department store mannequin but like a
human model made for art and educational
purposes it actually resembles a lot of
the figurines Charlie had been piecing
together throughout the movie notice how
its hand is making a gesture with two
fingers and a thumb crossed over this is
taken from medieval art showing Christ
but this gesture is inverted suggesting
the Satanic version of this
there's also Charlie's decapitated head
with a steel pronged halo which the
director actually took for me
18:58 polish film called ashes and
diamonds which had an upside-down
crucifix that was depicted with the same
kind of unsettling halo there's also a
picture of Annie's mother Ellen with the
word Queen suggesting this cult adorned
Ellen as the head of the hereditary
bloodline that would bring about payment
arrival and of course Joan and Dowd's
character whom we now know was a key
player in this cult greets Peter as the
name Peyman and Charlie crowning him and
proclaiming in her great aunt Lydia
voice hailed Peyman so who is Peyman
well Damon is the name of a spirit from
real-life pagan mythology he first
appeared in a work called the Lesser Key
of Solomon described as one of the eight
kings of hell a master of art and
science and one of Lucifer's most
obedient devotees I feel like I'm gonna
need to burn some sage after researching
this Damon is often depicted with a
woman's form but it's considered
masculine that is why despite taking a
female form initially in the movie
Charlie he really desires a vulnerable
male Peter
Peyman has the power of making spirits
disappear reanimating the dead and
flight all of which we see in the movie
actually in these written descriptions
the name Peyman apparently comes from an
unspecified language but it apparently
translates to a tinkling sound which
could be the origin of Charlie's clicks
and seeing the movie in this way is
kinda nuts but like similar horror
called conspiracy movies like Rosemary's
Baby or The Wicker Man the Indian ties
together an intricate plot that had been
in the works since the beginning so what
was the cults plan
Annie's mother Ellen led the Colts
planning for her bloodline to provide
Peyman with the male host body he sought
Annie actually explains that her brother
hung himself blaming their mother for
putting people inside him so it sounds
like Ellen's first attempt failed and he
also reveals that she never wanted to be
a mother saying that Ellen pressured her
but despite her mother she refused to
let her mother be around Peter as a baby
so Ellen's second attempt failed
but then when Charlie was born Annie
finally relented and let Ellen attach
herself to the girl and Ellen actually
insisted on feeding her now it's not
clear if Annie meant breast feeding
which would be pretty weird but it is
clear that Ellen fed Peyman spirit into
her granddaughter resulting in in
Charlie's dark behavior yeah she was you
know let's be
a little off still Ellen always wanted
Charlie to be a boy remember that was
confirmed by Annie finding the
embroidery reading Charles by the way
it's also worth mentioning the possible
significance of the names here Charles
the first was an English king who was
famously decapitated during the
restoration period and Peter was the
name of the founder of the Christian
Church known for being crucified upside
down so Charlie was always intended to
be sacrificed by this cult and for
payment spirit to be reattached to Peter
Charlie it's talks by members of the
cult who stare at her during Ellen's
funeral and at school she foreshadows
her own decapitation by cutting the head
off the bird and on the way to the party
with Peter you can briefly see the post
that she later gets to capitated on and
it features a very subtle carving of the
same symbol on the necklace worn by
Ellen and Annie and later painted a
blood in the Attic clearly the symbol of
payment then later after Charlie's death
annie attends group counseling after a
leaflet is slipped in with her mail
probably by joan who was actually
Ellen's close friend at one of these
meetings joan approaches her and the two
former relationship joan tricks her into
conducting a seance but this is not a
seance for Charlie Charlie are you there
Annie recites a series of Latin words
that actually open the door for payment
you know looking back I'm pretty sure
these words are the same ones that have
been carved on the walls of the house
which we saw in tight close-ups
throughout the film I definitely heard
Annie say the word Rex which I know is
Latin for King while this is all
happening the husband Stephen learns
Ellen's grave has been desecrated and
dug up presumably this was by the cult
unearthing Ellen's corpse and sneaking
it into the Attic in preparation for the
ceremony and the Colts ultimately
succeeds when Annie and Stephen are
killed and Peter's body is taken over
but how does this demon stuff relate to
everything else we saw in the movie the
dollhouse imagery and he's sleepwalking
and the themes of mental illness and
dealing with tragedy in a family
basically was any of it in Annie's head
well it all depends on how much you see
this story as a metaphor on one level
hereditary is a straightforward demonic
possession story Annie's sleepwalking
and mental illness could just be a
reflection of her mother's supernatural
manipulation and interpreting this as
mental illness is really just a
misdirect within the movies mystery
structure we initially see Annie's
problems as clinical because the movie
is largely through the eyes of Stephen a
skeptic then after he
Dyess the movies true demonic nature
comes alive however the way moving like
Rosemary's Baby was seen as an extended
metaphor for rape culture a victim
blaming hereditary is an extended
metaphor for the fear of inherited
complexes Annie and Peter are afraid
that they possess inherited mental
issues from their parents that are
beyond their control
this fear manifests into literal demonic
possession but the characters process it
the way real people process fear of
inner demons coming from their parents
this fear leads the main characters to
lose their minds which also physically
manifests into them literally losing
their heads in Annie's case she
processes to her pain by building
miniature sets this is a clear attempt
by her to be the master of her own world
to control things that she has no
control over this includes restaging the
death of Charlie something she was
helpless to Brent actually look back at
the movies opening shot it gives us all
the information we need to understand
this film it hints that despite the
focus on Annie and Charlie this is
actually a movie about Peters awakening
and by placing his bedroom within one of
Annie's miniatures it suggests that all
the events in this movie are taking
place in a dollhouse outside of these
people's control they are being
manipulated by a higher power the
filmmakers even went to the trouble of
constructing an elaborate life-sized
dollhouse set to match
Annie's miniatures that tells us that
demonic manipulation was the true story
of hereditary from the opening frames
expressing it through the lens of family
trauma was the movies way of connecting
to this conspiracy on an emotional level
but a question for you guys I'm curious
about what do you think was the most
frightening moment of hereditary for you
this movie had so many jump cuts to a
seemingly non scary shot but with creepy
stuff snuck into the frame for me it was
that shot of Peter in bed with Annie's
possessed body floating in darkness in
the corner and like took me ten seconds
to see it the pants are still wet
comment with your thoughts down below or
tweet me directly at a box and following
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos like and share this video and
subscribe the new rock stars for deep
dives into all kinds of movies like this
we've done similar analyses of a quiet
place and it in annihilation thanks for
watching